in an alternative Universe I think Bibi
would be a superhero she'd be able to
fly maybe not well because her balance
isn't great maybe like reading people's
minds she would be wearing something
definitely with a cape especially when
she was flying I think it would be quite
beautiful
all right the color of her costume would
be a purple costume it's Royal it's
regal and she's a bit of a queen her
name would be bad
I see BB fighting the male patriarchy
Reuben her a son would be an excellent
sidekick he would charm his way out of a
lot of uncomfortable situations but yes
I feel like they would be a superhero
fighting crime and men dream team
if we were to put Grace in an alternate
reality I would have her as liberated as
she could possibly be she would be madly
in love with the kindest most gorgeous
generous man and she would never be
ashamed of herself at the same time can
you imagine if she ran a huge charity
maybe she'd be like a surprising Eco
Warrior she has this massive big empty
hole that needs to be filled with people
who have a fire in their belly so that
she gets one too I think the Garvey
girls cannot live too far apart there's
a huge love magnet that just summons
them all together in whatever Universe
there will always be the invisible
string that keeps them together
thank you